en este vídeo quiero presentarte al
número y al número que también se le
conoce como la unidad imaginaria le voy
a poner por aquí unidad unidad
imaginaria y imaginaria
muy bien este número y es un número un
poco más extraño de otros números que
nos hemos encontrado en matemáticas como
pi y como y lo que le sucede a este y es
que no tiene una definición como muy
tangible no tiene un valor así fijo
más bien se define de la siguiente
manera se define como aquel número que
cuando se eleva al cuadrado da igual a
menos uno entonces esto de acá estoy acá
es la definición de y esto de aquí es la
definición de iu y con esta definición
se van a poder deducir muchas cosas
interesantes sin embargo antes de pasar
a eso me gustaría contarte que hay
algunas personas que los definen de otra
forma también se puede definir y como
que y es la raíz cuadrada la raíz
principal la raíz cuadrada principal de
menos 1 y esto es correcto de hecho
algunas personas a lo mejor te van a
decir que esto está mal pero ellos van a
estar mal después platicamos con eso con
un poco más de calma pero ahorita pues
si tiene sentido es decir que es igual a
raíz de menos 1 de hecho tiene bastante
sentido verdad si algo es la
1 entonces al elevarlo al cuadrado da
igual a menos después veremos porque hay
que ser cuidadosos con este símbolo
sobre todo cuando estamos hablando
acerca de números imaginarios y de
números complejos pero por el momento no
hay que preocuparse tanto por eso sale
lo que quiero hacer más bien es empezar
a explorar las potencias de ahí quiero
ver cuánto es a la 0 a la 1 a la 2 y así
sucesivamente como y al cuadrado es
menos 1 seguro van a empezar a pasar
cosas interesantes y en efecto va a
quedar bien padre mira vamos a empezar
calculando y a la cero entonces aquí voy
a tomar otro color déjame poner este
color azul hito para poner aquí
a la 0 entonces y a la 0 cuánto es bueno
pues cualquier número elevado al acero
incluyendo ahí es igual a 1 como
cualquier cosa la 0 es uno y al a cero
es igual a 1 muy bien ahora vamos a
poner y a la una hasta ahorita nada nada
muy difícil verdad elevar algo a la 1
pues de esa cosa cualquier número
elevado a la uno quiere decir que lo
multiplicamos una vez casi sin ninguna
otra cosa entonces y a la un
es igual
ahora elevar al cuadrado es sencillo
porque tenemos la definición entonces
vamos a ponerlo por acá y al cuadrado
según la definición es igual a menos 1 y
ahora ya van a empezar a pasar cosas un
poco más padres porque qué sucede cuando
ponemos al cubo voy a ponerle aquí y al
cubo y al cubo es igual a y mira le
vamos a hacer así para calcular las
potencias y al cubo lo vamos a escribir
como y al cuadrado x y simplemente estoy
usando las leyes de los exponentes
verdad bueno este y lo podemos pensar
como a la 1 entonces aquí sumando 1 con
2 nos queda este 3 entonces lo
reescribimos así y aprovechamos que y al
cuadrado es menos 1 para entonces esto
de aquí es igual a menos 1 esté aquí es
un -1 por y a la 1 que es y y nos queda
igual a menos y muy bien entonces y al
cubo es igual a menos y eso ya se ve
medio padre verdad déjame seguirle con y
a la cuarta de este lado y voy a tomar
el color azul de nuevo y no va a ser por
casualidad y mira vamos a calcular y al
a
misma idea este y a la cuarta lo vamos a
separar en un y al jugo por ti y al cubo
por y y al cubo ya vimos cuánto es es
igual a menos y entonces déjame cambiar
este y al jugo por un menos y menos y
sale pero llegó luego este menos y lo
tenemos que multiplicar por y cuánto es
menos y por y bueno pues éste esté menos
y eso es exactamente lo mismo que
pensarlo así verdad como menos 1 por y
por y simplemente estoy usando la
propiedad asociativa para repartir este
menos y pasarlo para acá pero ve aquí
tenemos otra vez y al cuadrado aquí hay
un y al cuadrado y ese y al cuadrado es
un -1 entonces tenemos menos uno por
menos uno menos uno por menos uno es uno
entonces y en la cuarta mira esto está
bien padre a la cuarta es igual a uno
y aquí como que uno siente que las cosas
se van a empezar a repetir pero vamos a
ver que de veras eso pasa mirábamos con
iu a la quinta y a la quinta es ya la
cuarta x y y a la cuarta ya lo
calculamos aquí arriba ya vimos que es
igual a 1 nos queda uno por iu y esto es
igual a iu y bueno parece ser que va a
seguir así verdad 1 y menos uno menos y
vamos a ver que haya deberás pasar eso
entonces déjame tomar el color rojo para
poner y a la sexta y a la sexta es igual
a y a la quinta por iu y a la quinta ya
lo calculamos acá arriba es igual a i y
x y pues y por y es y al cuadrado nos
regresamos a la definición y al cuadrado
es menos 1 entonces aquí nos queda igual
a menos 1 y así es el patrón sigue y
sigue de hecho esto nos va a ayudar en
vídeos posteriores a calcular exponentes
o más bien ha elevado a potencias muy
grandes a exponentes muy grandes vamos a
verse en el siguiente vídeo ahorita nada
más déjame poner ya la séptima para ver
que el patrón sigue funcionando
voy a poner aquí a la séptima y observa
y a la séptima es y a la sexta por y que
es igual a menos uno por y que es igual
a menos y entonces tenemos uno y menos
uno menos y 1 - 1 - y y así se va a
seguir circulando sucesivamente